clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci abonne toi c'est leur nom
khoma oui j'arrive en bas que tu fais tu
te caches attends tu fait des claquettes
là à me dit rien des castagnettes c'est
des castagnettes
non non c'est mais dont j'ai froid tu
claques des dons pourquoi tu fais ça
c'est la toile faut poser la question
c'est pas faux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand on a froid il se passe plein de
choses qu'on comprend pas forcément par
exemple on se met à claquer des dents si
c'est une technique pour impressionner
le froid a priori ça marche pas très
bien alors pourquoi on fait ça eh ben je
vous le donne en mille ça c'est quand il
fait très froid
la priorité des priorités de notre
organisme
c'est de maintenir au même niveau notre
température corporelle interne notre
température centrale pour protéger et
pour permettre le bon fonctionnement de
nos organes vitaux pour ça
quand il à l'information que la
température extérieure baisse par
l'intermédiaire de petits capteurs
nerveux qu'on a sur la peau notamment y
met en place un certain nombre de
stratégies dans un premier temps il
diminue la taille des vaisseaux sanguins
qu'on a à la surface de la peau pour
éviter que la chaleur s'échappe par là
donc tout ça ça se contracte et et c'est
la raison pour laquelle on a les tétons
qui pointent et le pénis qui devient
tout petit si on a un pénis on en avait
déjà parlé dans une vidéo je vous remets
le lien dans la description mais je ne
résiste pas au plaisir de vous remettre
un extrait celui de romain et sa célèbre
limitation du pénis qui se rétracte
oh je le fais y perdre
pardon je m'égare je me trouve donc ça
c'est la première étape celle pour
essayer d'empêcher que la chaleur
quittent notre corps mais notre corps il
a aussi des techniques pour essayer de
produire de la chaleur
alors nous autres commun des mortels on
n'est pas équipé pour faire monter la
température comme ça de façon
instantanée encore pour la thermogénèse
c'est-à-dire pour réussir à produire de
la chaleur
notre organisme a plusieurs moyens il
peut jouer sur le métabolisme en
bidouillant des réactions chimiques et
biologiques
mais le plus efficace ça reste les
muscles et sa l'hypothalamus
il le sait c'est un peuple excusez moi
oui et c'est quoi la l'histoire du
tripode mois l'anus 1 l'histoire deux de
l'hypothalamus
tu veux dire parce que moi en fait
j'avais coupé oui mais on sait ce que du
coup je pensais que c'était un moyen de
se réchauffe voilà on sait à quoi tu
penses est oui alors en fait
l'hypothalamus c'est cette partie de
notre cerveau
il fait plein de trucs et parmi ces
nombreux de boulot il ya la
thermorégulation justement c'est à dire
le maintien de la température corporelle
c'est plus clair comme ça ah oui et donc
rien à voir avec n'ont donc
l'hypothalamus si c'est que pour
produire de la chaleur
il peut compter sur les muscles du cou
quand il a l'info que la température
extérieure baisse il leur envoie l'ordre
de se contracter de manière répétée
c'est sa façon à lui de sautiller sur
place pour se réchauffer sauf qu'en
l'occurrence est un peu moins et la mode
ils demandent juste des contractions
répétées du coup ça a une première
conséquence les muscles de la mâchoire
il s'exécute du coup ça s'ouvre et se
ferme et les dents s'entrechoquent on
claque des dents autre conséquence les
autres muscles du corps ils font la même
chose
et du coup ça donne ces tremblements
caractéristiques qu'on a quand on a
froid on grelotte
donc voilà c'est aussi bête que ça si on
claque des dents si on grelotte c'est
juste qu'on essaye de produire de la
chaleur pour se réchauffer on s'en rend
pas compte sur le coup mais c'est juste
une façon de tenir nos à bas à bonne
température
ça al'air anecdotiques comme ça
néanmoins il faut savoir que si notre
température centrale des centraux on
peut se retrouver en hypothermie et
qu'il ya un risque vital alors juste un
truc de façon disons plus consciente
on a aussi nos petites stratégies
personnelles pour lutter contre le froid
genre met plusieurs couches de vêtements
savez la fameuse technique de l'oignon
ça c'est plutôt une bonne idée ou genre
boire un petit coup de gnôle 1 est la
moins bien pas bien du tout l'alcool ça
donne l'impression de nous réchauffer
mais en fait c'est tout le contraire
ok quand on boit un coup ça fait chaud
dans le gosier parce que ça pique un peu
mais si ça donne un coup de chaud au
visage c'est parce que l'alcool ça
dilate les vaisseaux sanguins notamment
ceux à la surface de la peau et du coup
la circulation sanguine laisse échapper
de la chaleur mais ça justement ça va à
l'encontre de tous les efforts que notre
corps est en train de faire pour garder
la température à l'intérieur donc ça
expose à l'hypothermie avant de se
quitter
je sens poindre chez vous une
interrogation vu que mon corps fait
plein d'efforts pour garder la chaleur
en dedans de moi vu que le pipi c'est
chaud pourquoi est-ce que le froid ça
donne envie d'uriner
excellente question vous vous en doutez
bien ça n'a pas fait l'objet d'études
scientifiques de grande ampleur mais il
ya deux explications qui sont avancés
d'abord on pense que le froid et toutes
les modifications qu'ils impliquent ça
perturbe un petit peu le système nerveux
et que ça a des répercussions sur la
vessie qui est un organe
particulièrement énervé est
particulièrement sensible
vous même vous savez et puis on avance
aussi une autre théorie qui est
directement liée à la vasoconstriction
c'est à dire les vaisseaux qui se
contracte dont on a déjà parlé
vu que la taille des vaisseaux à la
surface et au niveau des extrémités
diminue il ya moins de 100 dans les
vaisseaux en surface dont il y en a plus
dans les vaisseaux à l'intérieur du
corps du coup mécaniquement ça fait
monter la pression donc l'attention
c'est de la plomberie
dans ces cas là pour relâcher la
pression
le corps il va tenter de faire baisser
la quantité de liquide et pour ça il va
mettre en veilleuse une hormone qui
s'appelle l'hormone anti du
la tique et qui est chargé de retenir
l'eau en temps normal la conséquence
c'est que les reins évacué plus de
liquide dans la vessie donc on a envie
de faire pipi
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien